[Music]
making millions online is pretty
impressive watch our video to see how
these teenagers made their portions
online and hit the red button down below
to subscribe to our Channel then
pasternak at just 15 Ben Pasternak
created his first game impossible rush
it was downloaded more than 1.3 million
times and then he had another idea
but the Australians parent said he could
only drop out of school and move to New
York if he could raise the money for his
new app and he did to the tune of nearly
2 million dollars
thanks to Silicon Valley investors at 16
the tech tycoon launched his million
dollar app blog worldwide it lifts
teenagers buy and sell items with a
swipe benjamin kippah lushniak then
cable ethnic is known as the seeker Don
because the teenager is one of the top
sneaker resellers in the US and just 16
he was selling to the general public
through his website and two rappers and
professional athletes like P Diddy
French Montana and DJ Khaled - he
started selling to classmates in middle
school then he opened his own page on
Big Cartel then went on to make
connections with online stores and now
he has an inventory of close to 5,000
pairs Nash Grier Nash careers funny six
second vine videos made him famous as
just 16 he's now one of the most popular
Viners with billions of views and he
earns big bucks through sponsors Nash
has had contracts with companies like
Virgin Mobile and Sonic his endorsement
deals can pull in hundreds of thousands
of dollars so it's no wonder he was
named in times most influential
teenagers list and that his net worth is
in the millions Jalen Bledsoe Jalen
Bledsoe has done more by 15 than most of
us do in our entire lives at just 13
Jalen started a tech company
let's--oh technology specializes in web
design and IT services over the next two
years expanded into global enterprise by
the time he was a high school sophomore
he had 150 contracted employees and his
company was worth around 3.5 million
this remarkable teenager even helped get
his middle school cafeteria to serve
vegetarian options Sanjay and trevan
Kumaran if you thought starting a
company as a teenager was impressive
what about starting a company before the
age of 13
that's where brother Sanjay and trevan
Kumaran did they created their own
gaming corporation go dimensions and
developed free apps for the Apple Store
that were monetized through ad they
learn programming and coding by reading
a lot of books and have gone on to
create their own virtual reality device
called so VR Robert named Robert ney was
just 14 when he launched his mobile
gaming app bubble balls and it made him
a fortune straight away the game earned
over 2 million in its first 2 weeks of
release and 3 years on it had been
downloaded more than 60 million times at
17
Robert was rich enough to make a very
successful career out of developing more
games under his own brand names Robert
McCune it's not many part-time
McDonald's workers make millions
but Robert McCune did at 16 the college
student learn the basics of binary
trading while running errands at a
finance firm and by 17 he started
trading from his bedroom while working
shifts at the fast food chain by 19 he
was a millionaire he bought himself a
gold Bentley and he bought his mom a
house in the car but he hasn't forgotten
his roots
Robert has drained his McDonald's
uniform and hung it on his wall Rebecca
Black Rebecca Black became massively
famous when she was 13 thanks to the
catchy tune Friday the video was
uploaded to YouTube in 2011 and it got
more than a hundred million views in
just over a month making it the fastest
spreading amateur viral video ever it
might have been considered the worst
song ever by many but Rebecca made a
mint she toured talk shows and hired a
talent manager Jacob Sartorius
Jacob Sartorius was 11 when he uploaded
his first vine his anti-bullying message
went viral and his social media feigned
again but it was when he joined
musically that Jacob really got big his
lip-syncing videos led to him signing a
record deal he released his debut single
in 2016 and he became the ninth most
searched musical artist of 2016 after a
solo mini tour
Jacob rounded out 2016 by announcing his
EP called
the last X and an accompanying world
tour Danielle perkily cash me outside
how about that chances are you've heard
this phrase plenty of times and it's all
thanks to Daniel for goli the 13 year
old made a big impression during her
time on dr. Phil show about waiver
teenagers so much so that she's set to
make a million by the end of 2017 she's
making tens of thousands of dollars out
of Instagram product placements and
meeting grades at her own reality show
into the mix and it's clear why she's
worth so much
which teenager has done the best tell us
in the comments and give our video a big
thumbs up
[Music]
you
[Music]